So let's wrap up our discussion for today and
also wrap up the foundational unit of our course as a whole. We started off
today by revisiting this notion of Cognitive architectures that we talked about
at the very beginning of the course. We use that to contextual our discussion of
Production systems, specifically those implemented in a framework called SOAR.
As we saw, production systems enable action selection.
They help us map percepts in the world into actions. Of course,
this is only one of the many things that a production system can do.
It can really map any kind of antecedent into any kind of consequent. But
in our example, we saw how the production system for
a pitcher can map percepts from a baseball game into pitch selection.
We then talked about impasses and how when a production system hits an impasse,
it can use chunking to learn a new rule to overcome that impasse.
This is the first time we've encountered learning in our course, but
learning is actually going to be foundational to everything we talk about from
here on. This wraps up the fundamentals unit of our course.
Next time we're going to talk about frames,
which we actually saw a little bit of today. Frames are going to become
a knowledge representation that we'll use throughout the rest of our course.